[Music]
three two one action
hey guys on the back top the record
where we talk about what and Gina's here
she looks like a fucked-up version of
boo from Monsters Inc oh yeah I didn't
do my things very well I didn't have
much time did you even do that I didn't
see you do it I'm even have my proper
materials out of use rubber bands but I
think that I've been getting a little
bit of headache like I think because my
hair so long now that if I leave my hat
on too long it like you don't get
headaches from well it doesn't look like
you did it very tight but usually I'll
get hate headaches if I have a ponytail
it's too tight to well he does pigtails
because it relieves the stress on both
sides of his head if I let it go this
way like an antenna store and you look
like what's up god what's that old
Japanese man with the cats in the
schoolgirl nice piece yes you know the
nice piece guy he looks like Gollum I
ain't a [ __ ] schoolgirl outfit you're
not you're going in that direction
what's fun do you think that's my future
Joe used to be a gangster so I wonder
like what Joe's homies oh they tell me
straight up
they say funny things but I think they
all do funny funny see that's PC okay
funny things I would imagine
okay there's locker room talk right yeah
now imagine jail locker room talent yeah
jails have locker rooms well if there
has a locker is technically a giant
locker room Wow
it was it was I I call I've been called
the homosexual variety okay I have been
called but what do you say back nothing
you tell that your prison pocket is not
loose that's right
that's right hmm actually wants to do a
series like like prison yard Joe a
prison yard 101 and just learn how to do
a bunch of random things there's videos
on there there's videos there's videos
on YouTube where prisoners are showing
you how to make spread
how'd it like do all these things that
in jail maybe they should make one on
pocket [ __ ] too that would be pretty
awesome
sure there's one out there how to make a
Fifi bag well I wanted to I don't
imagine Fifi be the series with my dad
and I really don't want to learn no okay
well your dad's gonna look at it with
very fond eyes oh very well made
sweetheart
I would use that in prison yeah he's
like can we make the Fifi bag tiger I
need to come in
oh it's not like what it used to be man
dude there's there's prison tick tock
really yes cell phones in and there's
like pretty good there's a guy that I
follow it's a fitness guy in prison and
he's like he's trying to motivate the
rest of the world I guess to inspire to
be more well this fools like doing
push-ups on a cot like he's inside oh
this is crazy
I'm gonna Beyonce talk one night at four
in the morning since he was prison dude
with the barbell shirt on look what I
mean yeah what did he do to get to get
in I don't know man they could get
anything in there I wouldn't be
surprised if there's someone gaming like
there's a cholo right now with the full
gaming chair yeah yes the head gear and
he's [ __ ] streaming on Twitch I'll
shoot you like I [ __ ] did last week
and that's why I'm in prison
oh it's my yard time I'll see you later
all right green screen with the crayons
that they use in the art class do you
have a green tree I do
that's sir idea is it hard to do it
seems hard to use a green screen live
that's literally the dumbest [ __ ]
person in this room and I figured it out
so how come okay okay okay
I can't figure it out at all [ __ ] the
stream oh wow very difficult to you guys
both play a video game and stream at the
same time I mean we'll do it differently
a lot of times when we're playing we
just don't talk or interact with the
chat its until it's afterwards so we
interact or some people do but I noticed
that when I try to keep an eye on chat
and play at the same time I'm absolutely
carbage Oh see I have a problem just
setting up the function I'm not even
talking about the actual doing it I
can't [ __ ] set up I get it set up
where I'm in the little window and the
game's up but then I can't move in the
game wow it's weird [ __ ] [ __ ] dude weird
I'm three years into it I can barely
figure it out I was [ __ ] with my
lights yes
for like an hour and I was late there's
somebody help you in the beginning yeah
like I have my friend set it up for me
but then eventually you're gonna run
into some weird random problem and then
you just sit there and cry until someone
this is it that's where I've been I will
talk are you trying to stream so yeah
I've been it's been requested but my my
people my Steve heads out there they
won't they won't be looking for me to
see your eyes peoples yeah and so
they're they're looking for me to stream
and I tried to set it up in as a goddamn
night nightmare I'm having my brother
come and check it out but he's not the
smartest cookie so what if you lose it
what if you need dumb people to figure
this out maybe that's the secret okay
dude no honestly like a lot yesterday I
went through the whole process of how I
was fixing my light and one of the other
streamers was on my stream he's like you
know all you have to do is just unplug
it and plug it back in so I just find
the hardest [ __ ] way to do things
why you do that why why you make a life
a complicated man I'm dumb life is it
like it's so easy that's my problem you
got a complicated it I can help you see
we we should did I'm telling you man we
should play some Grand Theft Auto on
there man
how are you fighting that be fired
asking for me to play games with you we
would love it let's do dumb [ __ ] I gotta
buy games and then I'll play okay yeah
but I scared you guys don't even know
how scared is man no cuz he was addicted
he was addicted to Grand Theft Auto
right he disappears
John has to go to rehab ik I please I
could please 72 hours straight oh yeah
Wow
if you give me a pee pee bag in a poopoo
bag and if I can force feed tube I play
straight we're gonna yeah don't mix them
up that'd be weird it's weird to some
people don't look somebody's you know I
wouldn't consider it what no I get that
man I feel like that's kind of we're
married attaboy pausing like remember in
this old movie called the Avatar where
the guy turns into a blue human I
actually feel like Avatar when I'm
playing Animal Crossing
because I cuz this is my whole island I
got my people there the people that I
get to visit I get to bond with my mom
over this game you play like your mom in
the game or you like on here
no she's playing with her little
literally playing with my mom I'm saying
you like her the way she in game okay
well here's the thing like me my mom
we've always had a very like uh sad part
rough really choppy relationship yeah
but in the game she's lovely
let her complete okay sorry
so we've always had like a rough
relationship we just never understood
each other and now we actually have a
common ground where we can like talk
literally for hours while we're playing
this game together so she's visiting my
Island or visiting hers or were gifting
things to each other like it's really
beautiful how like I can finally bond
with my mom because talking about this
game like there was just nothing to talk
to her about ever like who there was
just nothing there like zero
conversation we could never start
anything together that's why I love this
game cuz I'm like cool I actually get to
bomb to third or something
that's where I'm at cuz otherwise I only
talk to my mom about my grandma's feet
and I'm like I want to talk about this
can we talk about anything else no mama
no my MA I wish my mom did so they have
a common ground I think like bonding it
through skill is one of the best yeah
that's actually what it is cuz before
that like my mom is a temperate person
just talk [ __ ] all day like it's really
her family too I noticed like after
spending time with her side of the
family I'm like Oh everyone's like this
where they can only focus on negative
things but always like this is this is a
laundry list of bad things happening in
my life and that's what I'm like oh
that's why I'm like the - mmm this is
what I grew up with and then like not
being near that 24/7 I'm able to like
see it and be like oh that's all they
know my mom runs away from that and
she's always shielded me I spilled it
water and when I'm around it I get
scared because I feel like it's
infecting my mind and it's poisonous
okay I'm sorry
if I keep hearing this
you farted in your mouth what pigtail
shake ey he says it fine god damn no
leave me that's you don't let her bully
you Jose marlon wayans and don't be a
menace but he wants to be in a serious
movie even if the gangsters bully you
out of it
don't let her do it yeah right yeah I
just don't understand what's so funny
I'm just talking and the thing that I'm
talking about it's not funny at all
continue Jeff yeah let me tell you
something about negative people okay
that shit's a [ __ ] virus yep when
they're talking I just want a diarrhea
and run yeah I just want to be a skunk
and fart on them and run oh that's
amazing
doesn't it feel like a disease like it's
heavy energy cuz sometimes I think
gossip is hilarious right cuz when
you're like roasting or like talking
about an event but if someone's always
talking about something that they're
like sad about like I'll be there for
you like sometimes but then like most of
the time I don't give a [ __ ] cuz like oh
the sadness isn't that sad you're like a
unicorn playing with your horn thank you
how do you escape things you how do I
escape he escapes with the game Jeana it
seems like and I abandoned people like
my dad oh yeah I just I just removed
myself from the situation out like I
just don't have those people this better
take pills more now you just look happy
Moll
I'm back to the old school that's a good
question I never thought about it how we
all do you don't escape by maybe
ordering some yummy food on post meats
that's a good escape that's a good ones
pretty solid that's true because when I
feel like I don't want to get up and go
shop or whatever I just order post mates
because post mates is pretty amazing
it helps me like when I need to escape
and be in my chill zone your house your
chill zone
it's my chill zone and I'm like can
somebody come give this to me because I
feel like sometimes we all need to be
pampered right but like our parents
aren't here anymore and I do you
remember the days when your parents like
are you thirsty let me give you some
water oh I had wonderful parents so
that's why they did that for me but then
so um I don't get that anymore but then
you know what I can do is I can order
post mates and pretend that the post
mates guy is my mom and say oh thank you
mommy and if you're like me you probably
started thinking about what for dinner
while you're eating lunch I love food
and that's why I love using post meats
they deliver food from every restaurant
I could think of right about through my
door but post mates don't just deliver
burgers and sushis they deliver they
make life easier with grocery delivery
and whatever I can think of delivery to
convenience stores clothing stores you
name it
maybe love I don't know if they deliver
love but then roses in a car so no more
trips to the store no more late-night
fast food runs I don't even have to
worry about where to grab lunch anymore
just downloads on iOS or Android find
your favorites and get anything you are
delivered within the hour for a limited
time postman's is giving our listeners
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app and use code
off the record that's cold
off the record for $100 of free delivery
credit with no minimum purchase for your
first 7 days when you download the pulse
mates
anything you need anytime you need it
postmates it yep that's a lot of dollars
$100 it surprises me every single time
even though I know it's happening
$100 for seven days that's how we feel
about you yeah yeah huh when you say
anything well I thought it was like $100
for seven days you feel surprised no you
surprise us every time even though I
know it's gonna happen what what is so
unpredictable about me I'm pretty
[ __ ] predictable actually yeah I
can't really cuz you do that some wild
[ __ ] and I'm just like yeah I'm you said
yeah we're numb to it but it is it is
provocative
very provocative other people it's the
people going yeah name one thing right
now hair your ponytail I remember the
first time I saw the ball of your foot I
was pretty surprised well especially cuz
he probably picked it up and dropped it
on the table there look at my feet and
we're like yeah man yeah I didn't know
if we can be that color
I guarantee you bar has the same feet
well you gotta go fart under the bus I'm
talking about you I've seen Bart's feet
and I was like that's surprisingly not
bad thank you yeah but then you put up
your foot once and it was a weird color
and also I think there was a whole flap
of skin hanging off yeah with the
blistered beats dirty today cuz I'm
barefoot today she just pointed out I'm
barefoot a lot and then also you you
have expressed the fact that you do not
scrub your body when you shower so do
they always okay I do but like I use a
sponge or a apparatus like a deep scrub
once a month but then I do I do a hand
scrub every day or no the old Asian
parents with these [ __ ] I asked you
you can do this one and by the way I'll
be taking like bats at night soaking
this [ __ ] skin you drop the water you
sometimes do you boil it it's fine
I don't want to waste water right so
then you're the same bathwater again for
the next night no okay so like I do this
thing where it's not like ice bath
but it gets extremely cold still like
when the window bathtub like the next
day it gets cold right so then I'll do
like a breathing exercise and not go in
and I'll just dip my body in the cold
bath real quick brown water yeah and it
cuz it's better than a shower and then I
drained the and I drain it
but then that same day like if I take
another shower I'll get the soap and
sponge and I'll give it a good scrub so
there's no [ __ ] filth in that bed in
a tub and then I make another bath our
bath is your escape I would say so
have you tried bath bombs uh I'd get
these Japanese ones that's like fizzies
yeah what's your escape Steve I would
say writing for sure yeah it's the best
for me cuz then I'm just completely out
of this world or space things watching
space movies or space documentary of
space I'm obsessed man I know I don't
know you like Venus did you say penis
and sir Mars Mercury Venus get the order
are you raising him right to think that
Pluto is a planet that's what we all
believe he doesn't think it's a part oh
he needs to know this is Bhutan setup
Pluto he says Bhutan and he calls the
solar system and I think he thinks the
moon is a planet too cuz he names the
order like he goes like was like Mercury
Mars whatever Jupiter and he goes like
Earth Moon so he says it's like you it's
like a small planet does cute mom damn
he knows this orders
he knows the order like he'll say it an
order from the Sun how do you learn it
we spend a lot of time teach
[Laughter]
he just gravitates towards like teaching
YouTube stuff so he has YouTube kids so
he just watches [ __ ] the [ __ ] that most
kids would think is [ __ ] boring loves
it okay you said he gravitates has some
spaceship yeah joke what's your escape
art is it the gym I think it's the gym I
think I really like like when I'm in the
gym I'm just training I'm like you know
they say like you get in that flow state
like I think like also when you create
art or cook that's like this flow state
where there's you lose sense of time and
space
oh yeah Animal Crossing for sure yeah so
you in the flow statement oh sure what's
like five hours passed yep I think the
gym is mine dude recently I think the
last time I did this I must have been
like 21 or something but I stayed up
till 5:00 in the morning playing this
[ __ ] game starting from when oh I
don't even remember yes no nice that's
you every day what game its you every
day what game do you think Steven yeah I
just wanted to say together but yeah I
was like what do you I start though like
5 p.m. no I think I started first thing
in the morning [ __ ] was at 24 hours it
you're a real gamer now what change so
much in this video I want out every time
we cut stuff out of this video I try to
do the bads again but I couldn't so I'm
just like [ __ ] it let me figure
something else you party I know it's a
corny History Channel
we're awake before I don't chose hair
looks face bro this looks like a wig why
that's so great it's let's make the
whole video like black and shiny black
dude ha you look like the quintessential
nerdy Asian kid in every teen movie how
can I turn from that the businessmen bet
that you would make you have thick black
hair thick will happen I don't know
I guess maybe thank you mom so you were
in a flow state with animal crossing for
20 [ __ ] hours no I don't know how
many hours if he goes up like at 10 a.m.
that day so it's a yeah problem Wow did
you eat foods yes only because KC kept
me alive
Oh see that sounds like a fun time to me
yeah welcome I want to do some kind of
thing like that
[Music]
[Music]